Perfect. Sounds good.
So, Himanshu, this side,
I look after the entire partnership
people just to move ahead at Short Hills.
I've been with the firm for more than a year at this point of time.
So, one year, three, four months at this point of time.
I started out as a tech consultant in
cybersecurity with EY, the transition into more of
business consultancy rules,
and was looking after majorly
BFSI, healthcare, such accounts,
and then got an opportunity to enter into Analytics and AI,
and that has been
the good thing and the bad thing that happened to me.
So, it just keeps me too busy to actually take a look at anything else.
So, I've been stuck,
fortunately or unfortunately with Analytics and AI.
Sorry, which bank did you say you came from?
So, I was previously at EY,
so I was working in a business consultant over there.
Oh, gotcha, gotcha, gotcha.
So, providing consultancy for,
so there are Southeast Asia banks,
so I was providing consultancy for a couple of them.
Then for North America, I was primarily looking after
a couple of education accounts as well as one of the largest
healthcare, sorry, farmer manufacturers, Rosh.
Thank you. Okay. Thank you.
So, that is where I come in from.
So, it's been sometimes for me for consultancy,
so I'm not fond of that.
Yeah, yeah.
Ratham, why don't you go next?
Passing on to you.
Perfect. Well, it's super great to meet you both.
I am Sarah Blum, my leader,
commercial sales team for the East Coast.
I've been with Databricks,
it'll be five years next month, which is crazy.
I spent four of that as an AE,
I'm a digital native sales team.
So, first time people leader leading the startups team here,
but it's been really fun.
So, I've got eight reps on my team.
We cover customers all along the East Coast.
Anything under 250 million in revenue or below
is really where we focus and I'm a core manager.
So, all of our customers are existing spenders.
Activities accounts.
That's nice. Yeah.
All right.
So, I'll just first of all,
congratulations on the five years.
When is the exact date?
I'll send you a congratulation note on that day.
It'll be, I think October 1st or October 5th.
I can't remember what day I started.
But yeah, first week of October.
All right then. Well, October is going to be a great month for you.
Yeah.
Five months.
So, before we really jump into it, I just wanted to...
So, we have been working...
Well, let me take a step back.
Let me just give you a little bit of an insight about Short Hills
and then we can take it forward about what...
Why I really wanted to have this conversation with you about.
So, Short Hills, so we have been working...
Partnership was not really some of the core strength for us.
We have been working on Databricks or providing services.
We are a consulting service.
We are a services implementation partner.
So, we have not really been very focused on the partnership front
and that is primarily why I was brought in.
So, we have been working on a couple of our customers
where Databricks implementation was taking place
or has been implemented by us,
particularly in regards to the data lake creation,
lake-based creation and building analytics on top of it.
At this point of time, we are Databricks silvery-day partners.
We are also brick-builder, GNI partners.
And yeah, that is sort of the major milestone.
Apart from that, just the regular thing that,
hey, we have 100-class engineers certified on Databricks and all that.
Awesome.
So, that is a very quick roundup of Short Hills
and where we stand with Databricks today.
So, why I wanted to have this conversation was,
I believe we started off the conversation with Drew and Isabelle
and meeting some traction over there.
We had a couple of interactions, Pamela, and things turned,
I don't know how to put it forward.
I've met her, I can only imagine.
So, I just wanted to get an update on that scenario
and to understand, hey, how we can take things forward.
Yeah, so, I was looped in to the situation with Pam and Daisy and works.
And I actually raised this to our legal team
because she got pretty aggressive with our sales team
and our support services.
I don't know if she's sent you guys a bunch of emails,
but she kind of sent a series of emails indicating legal action,
you name it.
So, long story short, we raised this to our legal team
and we're basically going to terminate the contract with her.
So, I've instructed my team not to engage
and frankly, I would encourage you both not to engage.
They don't have a business, they don't have a product,
they don't have revenue.
I don't know where you guys left things as a next step,
but we are not pursuing it.
She basically, Pam indicated she won't pay her invoice,
which will terminate the contract and then we'll move on.
So, I have instructed Isabel not to engage and talk to her.
Did you guys have a next step with her?
Did you have anything that you were going to do?
So, the last conversation which we had, so she was pretty agitated.
And that is what, at that point immediately,
I had contacted Drew and Isabel.
Hey, this is what I've heard and I want to be completely
transparent with you guys.
Hey, this is what I'm hearing.
Just take a look at it.
And then I realized that she had posted a couple of things
on LinkedIn as well.
So, want to be on the same page that,
hey, does not look like something that we can maybe take forward
from our side.
That is what I had communicated as well to Isabel and Drew.
Okay, yeah, I would just like thank you for meeting with her.
Thank you for offering to work with her,
but I would just disengage.
And I talked to Pam last week and told her,
like we're basically going to terminate the contract.
Like we're not just, we're going to go our separate ways.
It clearly wasn't a fit.
So, that's how we're leaving it.
And I just, I wouldn't even respond to her at this point.
Sounds good.
Yeah, so I was also having a little bit of concern.
Hey, what exactly is it that you're trying to create
and how do you intend to generate revenue to pay off?
What do you have, you know, taking up debts for?
No, yeah, it was all, I think just some major miscommunication
and misunderstanding.
So, yeah, we're not pursuing it.
You know, they're going to default on the contract
and we're just going to go our separate ways.
All right.
All right, that clears up the board of this scenario.
And hopefully such one of our currencies
that we can put this behind us.
Hopefully better opportunities in the future for sure.
So, I'll tell you the primary reason why I,
we have started reaching out as well.
Hey, we are Databricks partners, we are Silver Deer partners.
And we are engaging with a couple of Databricks account executives
as well, Drew included.
Isabel, we have only had a couple of conversations
primarily around Pamela and the previous conversation
did not work out.
And so what I wanted to have this call with you
was just to showcase, hey, this is where we stand.
This is what we do.
How do you propose a way forward for us?
I have, in fact, created a very short tip for you.
Let's know if that is visible.
So I can quickly walk you through it
and I can hear your thoughts on it.
Yeah, I would love to know, like,
what types of industries or use cases you specialize in?
And then just like general expectations on pricing and costs.
Like our customers are very cost sensitive.
And so my team prioritizes partners
who have low cost or investment offers.
So that's what I'm really more curious to learn about.
And yeah, that's,
I'm really more on information gathering for this.
All right, happy to oblige over there.
And I hope you come out of this conversation
with a little bit more info for us.
Perfect.
All right, so this is just a very big overview of,
hey, where we stand with and what we have delivered.
Some of the key things that we have been focusing on
are DTLA, obviously governance with the Unity catalog,
building custom analytics solutions on top of it,
and integrating, you know,
Chini dashboards or agenting dashboards with Chini,
previous AIBA dashboards with Chini,
that was what we were looking at.
And another thing that we have been taking up
are rule-based LLMs.
So see what one of the couple of things,
a couple of things that we are seeing in the market right now
are people are very,
they were very excited when AI came out
and they were very excited about,
hey, let's provide it to everybody in the organization.
And what that ended up doing is generating
just a lot of cost for them.
People are generating similar solutions
with different teams.
I mean, I may be a different team, Pratham,
maybe a different team,
and we are all,
we are both of us are generating similar solutions.
That's just ending up with more token consumption and cost
or token utilization for them.
So they are exhausting their credits
and they are seeing,
not as significant of,
an impact on their workloads as they were expecting.
So what we have been focusing more on is a rule-based LLM
model.
So we define custom rules for most of the tasks
that you are actually looking at.
So those rules, what ends up doing
is data picks up a cluster for every task
that is being implemented.
If all of the tasks are going out via LLM route,
then you're not really earning a lot of consumption over there.
Not a lot of the debuts are being consumed
because of just passing, for example,
you're passing all of the tokens through Unity catalog to Cloud.
Then you're not really consuming the debuts.
What we are looking at is, hey, let's
create custom rules for organizations, which we are
working with, so that what happens is all of the queries
are first handled by the system itself that we have created.
And if it is not able to answer those queries,
then LLM model is triggered.
So what happens is a cluster is spun up
and that ends up pulling in all of the debuts.
And if that does not work out, hey,
let's go forward with an LLM call.
Does that sort of make sense or have I lost you somewhere?
Yeah, this makes sense.
You mentioned you're already working with a silver tier.
You're working with a bunch of customers.
I saw some big logos on your website.
Who are you primarily working with today,
especially within Dan Tobin's org?
Within?
Within Dan Tobin's org.
Who are you working with on the emerging side of the business?
Dan, I'm not sure which one you're referring to.
OK, yeah, it's fine.
You can keep going.
I love to clear it out.
I maybe misheard something.
Yeah, I just am curious what other sales teams
you work with at Databricks or any other customers
within my segment?
Primarily, we're looking at a couple of accounts
would be what is it, Ascent, DCG, a couple of major drivers.
I believe DCG is one in the one of your patches,
but they have recently started more going
and move forward with the consumption.
So there was a tip over there.
And the other one is much more smaller player Park Circle.
OK, thank you.
All right, so this is something that I believe
might be interesting for you.
You mentioned that you're looking at very cost
effective or cost conscious partners.
So what we're looking at is, hey, if you have an enterprise
grade use case, if we can identify an enterprise grade
use case, which would be beneficial for both of us
in the long run, I would be willing to put forward
to AI engineers from my side plus a part time solution
architect for a period of one to three months.
Ideally, we would be looking at one to two months
for an AI use case.
But if it does come down to it, if the logo is worth it,
I'll be putting it for one to I will be willing to go forward
to one to three months.
It won't be any cost to the customer.
The resourcing cost would be on my side.
Obviously, the database consumption is
infra cost can be from your side supported,
or it can be on customers account.
OK, this is great.
Yeah, so what ends up happening is customer does not
have to really go forward with experimenting.
Maybe thinking of experimenting with custom
MCP agents or custom agent to care use cases.
What I'll be willing to put forward is I'll
be willing to put forward the workforce for that particular
solutions creation so that they can get a taste of what
is really possible with the power of AI and Databricks.
And if they're happy with it, if they're satisfied with it,
we can take it forward.
I have a question on this.
Like the one specific use case, do you time bound this?
Like I've got to imagine it's probably
hard to avoid scope creep.
So how do you keep this on a very narrow scope?
So first of all, since we are defining a use case,
at that point itself, we have a well-architected,
hey, this is the scope that we will be implementing for you.
So we have to avoid scope creep.
Otherwise, we'll keep on just going through the POC scope
itself.
It will keep on having a scope creep.
We'll keep on increasing the time duration.
So that is why we put a hard stop to, hey,
this is what we'll be implementing for you.
This is what we'll be generated and delivered to you
at the end of the day.
So that is agreed by between all of the parties, us, Databricks,
and the end customer.
Got you.
After the scope has been defined up, we obviously have to,
we have within the scope definition, we put forward,
hey, this is what the timeline for this would look like.
And this is what the engineers will be provisioning.
This is what we require from your end.
Hey, this is maybe we will require a separate server
for that particular use case creation or whatever
would be the requirement that is clearly specified
so that all of the parties into the exception,
what would be required to expand up and at the end of the day
into that POC.
Gotcha.
Thank you.
So once all of that has been defined up,
we start working on it.
Once the POC has been delivered, the customer is happy with it.
Then obviously, then we have to make that call.
Then we need to have that tough conversation with the customer.
Hey, now that you have seen what can really be done,
how do you want to take it forward?
So obviously, it results in more debut consumption for us,
more services business for me.
On the same page?
Yep, thank you.
All right, good.
This is just a little bit of a more in-depth deep dive
into what we will be looking at.
And this is just a little bit more
defined version of what I just explained to you.
Hey, we have a discovery call.
We define the scope that you would be going forward with.
Once the proof of the, once the KPI metrics have also been
defined up, then we see how it can be adopted by the organization.
And if it expands, it will result in additional commit for you.
I see.
I have a little bit of a bust.
Okay, I see.
Thank you.
All right.
And the right-hand side is what I was talking about.
Hey, I'm seeing a lot of things that are happening with,
you know, that it calls to the LLMs.
So this is something that we are looking to eliminate so that
a little bit more consumption goes through Databricks
and a little less via the Unity catalog.
So it actually ends up generating a little bit more revenue for
Databricks at the long run.
So you can see 20% reduction in token consumption and 15 to 20%
increase in, you know, the TVU consumption.
This would be 100% governed within Unity catalog.
Okay, cool.
All right.
These are the, you know, these are the primary areas that I want
to focus on.
A little bit of the history of the work that we have done
across digital native businesses.
We have been working with primarily marketplace lenders,
e-commerce solutions, e-commerce platforms.
Within the healthcare space, we have been working with
one of the largest providers.
You might be familiar with them, NHS in UK.
And we've recently started working on, you know,
Pharma side of these stuff as well.
But that is a little bit under the wraps for now.
Apart from that, we have experience with the taxation side of
stuff, you know, audit taxation compliance with one of the big
force.
So this is roughly where we stand.
And these are where my strengths lie.
Gotcha.
Well, thank you for the rundown on this.
It sounds like the way to think about it is if we need help with
like a very specific use case to prove value and then healthcare
and digital native is probably where you guys live most.
Healthcare, digital natives.
Yeah, that would be right.
Automotive, healthcare, digital native and automotive.
Okay.
We don't have any auto on our team.
Big force.
Yeah.
So that's why I don't jump into too much because I know you're
looking after digital natives primarily.
Yeah.
And the commercial business.
Well, awesome.
This was helpful.
I think right now the team is pretty focused on the
company.
Pretty focused on a couple investment partners that come down from
Dan's level.
So I'll just keep you guys in the loop and like keep you in mind if
there's opportunities that come up in the healthcare world or
digital native world.
Sounds fantastic.
So let me know how it turns out if conversation with Dan goes well.
Is that by any chance Dan Waterman, but I thought he was in UK.
No, not him.
Dan Tobin.
Okay.
No, I haven't had the fortune to connect with him.
Yeah.
And he's out for a while.
He's a maternity leave.
So yeah, I'll just say congratulations to him then.
Yeah.
No, it's exciting.
But no, I appreciate you making some time and I will, I will just
keep you guys in the loop if there's any opportunity, but I'd
say with Daisy and works and Pam just don't engage at this point.
We'll do.
You know, I've taken that to the heart.
But we are doing, we are keen to engage with Databricks as a
partner.
And as of right now, I believe we're engaging across startups
in digital data space primarily with what was it Travis, we are
engaging and a couple of other people.
Oh, great.
Yeah.
Travis is awesome on the hunter side.
So on the hunter side as well as on the DNB, I keep forgetting her
name.
So there was, yeah.
Okay, cool.
So it sounds like a lot of the hunter teams.
Yeah.
So do let me know.
If something pops up on your radar or if you're looking for,
or if any of your customers,
since you're looking after activated accounts,
if any of them are looking for something that they're looking to
create on the agent side or just trying to experiment with something,
we'd be happy to have that conversation.
Perfect. Appreciate the time. Have a good one guys.
You too. Take care.
Bye.